how does suspension of disbelief factor
into a great opening
the great a great opening is um
extremely important in terms of
how quickly your visitor
or audience member
buys into the world that you're creating
and
as much as you know it really starts
from the very very first
moment of
how you
you know when you think about like how
you um
walk down a path to get to the
experience or
you know the door that you open
or the person that greets you i think
that every single
detail and element that leads you to the
main experience
is something that helps to create that
suspension of disbelief
and you know it in my book i talk about
the walt's haunted mansion and how you
think about the fact that like the um
pavement that you walk on the the
graveyard that you go through the
wrought iron gate um the cast members
that greet you and have that tone
it's
immediately you get a sense
that you're no longer in the place that
you were just moments before
in
and i think that
being able to think about a story
in all of those elements not just
um telling a story verbally or
a story that's written to think about
how you create this immersive
environment that makes you believe
you are in a different place when you
think about
going to
travel to a different country for
example
the moment you get off a plane and go
through the airport and
you know
get into a taxi whatever it is and
arrive at a place immediately
you get a sense of uh it's a different
people
different culture a different language a
different way of doing things a
different different sounds different
smells different textures different
temperature
every time i think about creating an
immersive story world i think about
traveling because that's one of my
greatest passions and me in life is to
immerse myself in different countries
and different cultures and when you
think about how
every time you do travel to a new
country or a completely different place
there is this
sense of
excitement anticipation and adventure
and your visitor
wants that 100
they
paid for your experience you know maybe
it's free whatever but you know they're
committed
to your experience for that time period
and the better you can create that sense
of place
and to create that
belief that they are truly walking into
this world and this environment that
you're creating and
making it so seamless and consistent so
that the pattern doesn't break because
as humans we are pattern recognizers
so if you are in a time period that's
supposed to be the 1800s and then you
see some modern technology on the wall
it immediately takes you out you know
immediately so how do you think about
every single detail and element
that takes
and transports you
and your audience member into a place
that they are willingly
able to suspend their disbelief and
enter your world
and willingly and openly want to
participate and play and engage in it
then you've done your job well as a
storyteller
and that's something you know
a lot of different mediums are really
exploring and really trying to find ways
in which to
immerse audience members and um visitors
in new and unique ways and you know i
have to say video games do it very well
you know from
their
inception until now
just seeing it evolve and how as a
player you get to really immerse
yourself in that story world immediately
that's something that a lot of immersive
storytellers can really
think about when they think about
creating that world you know you think
about video games and how immediately
you are a character
who has a role in this world and you
have agency and whatever action you take
has consequences
you you know whether you turn left or
right or follow this character or not
follow that character and go somewhere
else all of these things have these
multi-branching stories and narratives
that you as a player can follow and
that's something that's very exciting um
in the immersive storytelling world to
explore and you know a really great
example is sleep no more in new york
city where you do
have this deconstructed narrative of
macbeth and you can follow these
characters in different rooms and
you follow a character in their
storyline and you
can explore a room on your own you can
meet people there's this sense of
mystery and exploration and discovery
that feels very very unique
and i'm excited to see
more and more of that how can people
really
push the boundaries of what immersive
storytelling is
and how can you really involve
not only
yourself as a participant but the people
around you
to create something
that feels like a shared narrative that
together you're experiencing and that
you're connecting on a deeper meaningful
level with complete strangers i think
that's
some of the greatest magic that i see in
immersive storytelling is that you're
able to find um
that human connection that many times in
our own lives maybe we've lost
and you said too two words that stuck
out to me too mystery and discovery and
i started to think about for myself why
i like certain stories and i think that
that's a huge component and you want to
talk about being present in something
yeah when our mind is going like that
right right and i think that you know as
humans
we want to make sense
of the world around us and that's why
you know mysteries and you know crime
stories murder mysteries all of that
we want to go down that rabbit hole
because we want to understand you know
we want to find a reason
for why people do the things they do
would i do the same thing if i were in
that same situation like all of these
what ifs right and um
what ifs and what really happened and
you know
what more can i discover what more can i
uh find if i follow that you know path
like that's why a story like alice in
wonderland right is so captive
uh captivating to us because
it's really following
a character that's
uh brave enough to go on that adventure
and for us to follow along on that
journey and to really
discover
what it means
when you are brave when you are fearless
when you do meet strange characters in
your life all of these things i think
like
there's an inner child in all of us
that has that curiosity and that desire
to discover and explore
the world around us
what are some great openings in
immersive storytelling
oh boy
when you talked about the greeting it
hadn't even thinking about even a
walking into a restaurant
in some sense is like there's a little
bit of storytelling but you talk about
greeters
and and and just taking you immediately
into that world and knowing that you've
left one world and going into another
yeah you know um there's one experience
that i have to call out
is called the nest in los angeles and
they
unfortunately they're closing soon so i
think people have a few weeks to book it
before it the production closes down but
it's an immersive uh world where
you know you you go into this building
and one of the first things they do is
put you into um
a really old rickety elevator
and you go up on this you know journey
that
very curious very mysterious and you
don't know what's really going on you go
up just you and one other person
goes up on this rickety elevator
and
you're basically uh told in a letter
that you've inherited
a storage unit
and so you go through the storage unit
and piece by piece you uncover the story
of this woman's life she has recently
passed away and through a very clever
medium which is just old-school cassette
tapes that you put into a cassette
player
in each of the rooms there's uh there's
actual activities that you're doing an
action that you're taking
uh to discover this uh woman's life
and everything from like uh you hear her
voice from
childhood to when she's an older woman
i think they really cleverly put that
together um these two uh former
imagineers who put this
experience together that was a really
great opener for me um a really
memorable one
where
you really feel transported and you do
suspend your disbelief to really explore
this um
creepy in fact a creepy environment for
you to really uncover the story of this
woman's life
that's fascinating so you said it's
closing down soon yeah in a few weeks in
a few weeks
forever um forever but they're probably
going to do other projects um but for
now
it's um
they
it was running for a few months maybe
i don't know don't no no don't quote me
on it it was running for a few months
but
um there it was a really clever way
to tell a story in a very contained
and controlled environment and the only
thing that you're given is a tape
recorder and a flashlight and so you're
going into this very immersive
from you know
hallway of a storage unit and at one
point you're developing um film
you know to look at some clues to open a
lock like all of these things and you
feel really emotionally invested to find
out
um really the story of what happened to
this
woman who left behind the storage unit
for you
that's fascinating so you get this
letter from like a barrister or an
attorney or whatever and it says you're
the you know beneficiary of this estate
yeah i think it was you won you won the
storage unit oh yeah okay yeah okay
interesting yeah then you and do you you
see parts of her life and not just here
yeah and it's all out of order too so
it's a non-linear storytelling
and um brilliant uh yeah so they really
did a
great job in putting that together and
really thinking about this is another
way like when you think about like you
don't have to have you know millions of
dollars to create an immersive story you
you simply use what's around you to best
represent the the feeling that you want
in creating this place
so
yeah the nest really i definitely
recommend that